- What up vlog?
Going live on Facebook
which I haven't been doing a whole lot of.
(hip-hop beat)
("Time To Go" by Ruslan)
Adri has two wine in his
I feel like
sometimes I go so macro
I don't take advantage
of the opportunity
in front of me.
You know, thinking so big with us
and kind of what we
talked about breakfast.
In the meantime,
I've now heard seven versions of your name
and I wanna
really own this right.
- [Man] I was gonna ask the same question.
- It's Andrea.
- I'm right.
Told you dick.
- [Drock] Andrea, yeah.
- You, no I said Andrea.
- [Drock] When?
- This morning you said
it, you said it differently
and it threw me off.
You're the one that actually scared me.
Yup, that's exactly what we did.
- [Drock] He likes Andrea.
- But it's Andrea.
It's like, was Andrea the 90210 character?
Yes, I knew it.
- [Drock] Is Andrea like,
what you wanna be called?
- Nope, stop saying it because
it's gonna get in my head.
Andrea.
I've been on point then.
I've been consistently,
thank you, thank you.
But you fucked me up this morning.
I was like, Drock's a
sensitive type of cat.
He might actually be right.
He might've like went
right to her face and said,
you know, so I was scared.
("Time To Go" by Ruslan)
Vaynermedia.com/4ds, right?
Vaynermedia.com/4ds, the 4d,
the daily digital deep dive.
It is changing small
and medium-sized businesses world.
Go on the website to get the date.
Instagram, I'm so sorry I
haven't posted all fuckin' day.
I'm just busy as shit running VaynerMedia
and if you guys know,
that's my actual job.
Dog Man and Cat Kid?
Well I'm in seventh
place right now on Amazon
in the world of most books sold,
and number five is Dog Man and Cat Kid.
Fuckin' christ.
Alright one more time.
Can I play music out
here like that one day?
- [Employee] Yeah.
- How?
- [Justin] Also I've been
really thinking about
a business idea.
- Okay.
- [Justin] So basically it's like,
a type of gym environment.
(bleep) have that environment.
So like a space, a space--
- Capital intensive.
The reason this is a tough business,
whatever comes out of your next mouth,
is it costs a million
dollars to even start.
- [Justin] Okay.
- Like not really, you could do it ghetto.
- [Justin] What if I started ghetto?
- Kinda like that.
- [Justin] This is 10 year and--
- Gym rats have gym equipment.
- [Justin] Right, I want
there to be (bleep) in it too.
- That's what I mean.
So you know like, you can do it though.
You just need to know
you're on a real long path.
- [Justin] For sure.
- Which is cool.
Like honestly, I know you.
Like, we're almost weirdly like that.
- [Justin] I'm trying
to play like, the game.
In so many ways like
I'm very similar to you.
And like, I was just thinking like,
and especially this past
week that I've been off,
I'm like, what do I really like?
I like music and I like doing
it the way I was doing it
because I was going
like the Christian route
which I'm Christian so like I wanted to
in some way be impactful.
And so (bleep)
- Probably why you like my stuff right?
Like I'm not necessarily religious
but I'm like very religious.
- [Justin] Right, exactly.
Like you're helping.
- Yeah exactly.
- [Justin] I like that,
that that's who you are.
So like, the reason why
I wanna do this (bleep),
I know it's like, it's gonna cost a lot
but like, I'd start ghetto as fuck.
I just wanted like advice on how to like--
- Where do you wanna do it?
- [Justin] It'd probably
be too expensive like
to start in Manhattan but
like, Queens, Brooklyn,
something like that.
- Dude, I'm super into it.
- [Justin] A franchise kind of thing.
Like place I have in Houston.
- So let me give you a great example.
You'd heard a lot of my advice
so you're gonna understand this.
When I hear that, I almost feel like
I want you to go intern for
(bleep) who start (bleep)
and runs (bleep).
- [Justin] Okay.
- I almost feel like I wanna pitch him
on the idea of doing like,
you doing for him what I
do, what VaynerTalent does.
So you could actually learn
the franchise business.
If you really wanna do that.
- [Justin] Yeah.
- If you really wanna do
that, you know how I say
go work for Puff Daddy or
Howard Schultz from Starbucks?
Well fuckin' one of the
gangster fuckin' people
in the game (bleep).
- [Justin] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like one of the top
franchisee people in the game
is my homie.
- [Justin] And you think that's the best--
- Always I think that.
Brother, do you how much smarter you are
by just sitting in the epicenter?
- [Justin] Yeah, you're right.
I get it.
- Dude that's the game always.
You got too much time.
You know how hard the
franchise business is?
99.9% fail.
You don't anything about
building franchise business.
You know what you wanna do.
But you've no idea of
how to have a business.
If you're really talking
about Atlanta and New Orleans,
you make the trade.
Like if you followed me every day,
you would understand how to
run an agency much better.
- [Justin] Right, but I'm
thinking something different.
- Go ahead.
- [Justin] No I mean like,
I'm different than this.
- Correct.
You wanna run a franchisee business.
Like you wanna build the
soul cycle of your thing?
Well then go work for
somebody who's built it
in a different way.
- [Justin] But my thing, my only concern,
- Go ahead.
- [Justin] If somebody
comes up with that before me
'cause even if somebody
does, I can make it better
and it just eats that out.
Does that sound like cheese?
- Never.
It's a young concern in the same way
that people wanna patent things
but it's not what the
world is really played on.
- [Justin] Okay (bleep)
- They exist already.
- [Justin] Right.
But I was meaning for like
everything like (bleep)
Yeah.
- You know?
That I'm not worried about at all.
The fact that you're
even thinking that way
is interesting than to get
you in front of somebody
who's built a business that way.
- [Justin] Okay.
- Like being a creator, this
is a master's class in it.
Building a brand, this
was fuckin' like Harvard.
Like it's happened in front of your eyes.
Even in the time you've been here.
- [Justin] Right.
- You don't anything about building
a location based business.
It's cool when you break it down right?
But you have the advantage of my cosign
and your craft that you
can bring to somebody
and again, Drock and Babin are smarter
about running the agency than Andy is.
'Cause they're in it watching.
So imagine watching (bleep),
you might be like fuck that
I'm not doing that, so we
have to go to the next person.
But that's always the
right move at this time.
You have it better than anybody
'cause I tell people go get
a job with P. Diddy but how?
You have my ability to
put you in the spot.
If that's what you wanna do.
You have to decide how, but
I could also see you lead
and I could see you leaving
here and being like (bleep),
know what I mean?
- [Justin] Also it's like
your energy is different
than those other.
I don't know if I would
click as well as I know you.
- Yeah, yeah that's a vulnerability.
- [Justin] And I don't know
if you feel that same energy
that we click.
- I feel like we click,
I feel like we click.
- [Justin] And I don't know
if it would be the same way
with another person.
- I get it.
- [Justin] That's one like worry.
- Because you're lucky
that you got the experience
with the comedy thing.
We haven't talked about it.
But like, right.
When you get under the
hood, everybody's different.
- [Justin] That was a positive experience.
- Good, the peeps.
- [Justin] Yeah, real good peeps.
- The first move is are
you willing to really
make this your next seven,
theoretically if it goes well,
are you willing to make this your next
three, five, seven, eight years?
- [Justin] I'm thinking life.
- Great.
So if that's true, then yes
I think you should go work
for somebody's who built
a franchise business.
I think it would be
unbelievably ROI positive.
I would even say if you
think the guy's a douche
and you don't click, eat
shit and just listen.
- [Justin] Okay, got it, cool.
- You know?
Like.
- [Justin] Yeah you're right.
- If that's really what you're--
- [Justin] I wasn't thinking
that that the was next move.
- I know, that's what mentors are for.
I know what you were looking at
and this is what, I wish I was smarter
and had mentors right.
Mentors will help you.
- [Justin] I was thinking
hella short term.
That mind was short term
thank you, but that is like--
- True long term.
- [Justin] How you would, right.
- You're trading your crub.
You're trading, you're
cashing in on the equity
that I always promise
which is get in with me,
you trade on your skill, go and do that,
but you're fuckin' sitting
there and fuckin' listening.
Remember how much you
learned just in one day?
- [Justin] Yeah, you're right.
- You hear him talking
about square footage
or why that location won't
work or like demographics.
You'll come out of it knowing shit.
- [Justin] Right.
And plus like the branding
social media side of all that,
like I've absorbed so much here, yeah.
- Way more, you don't
even realize how much.
Because when you get to the real world
and you're not playing in the majors,
it's like a basketball player.
Who only plays in the NBA.
And then they go play at the park
and they're like right, I'm really great.
- [Justin] Right.
- You know?
Just happens every time.
("The Effect" by F. Mills)
Please tell me you got that.
- Let's go.